einfach lächeln und winken ok sowie die
pinguine lächeln und welchen
aktion
hallo herzlich willkommen in mailand
datenwelt ich möchte heute das
gewinnspiel verlosen und hab euch jetzt
praktisch die ganzen gewinne bereit
gestellt und werde euch jetzt oder werde
beziehungsweise die gewinner verkünden
ich habe alles aufgeschrieben du
könntest auch dazu wäre okay die
sanierung schon im pinguin fieber das
war das gewinnspiel über die pinguine
von madagaskar und ihr hattet ihr dazu
mein video fleißig geteilt ganz viel
kommentiert und ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich bei allen die mitgemacht haben
und die mich unterstützt haben und mir
jetzt anders natürlich traurig die
gewinner verkünden so wissen weil es
sind ja nur 20 gewinner aber sagen ja
ganz viele kommentiert ganz viele
geteilt und am liebsten würde ich euch
ja immer alle gewinnen lassen aber das
geht ja im prinzip irgendwie gar nicht
und deswegen verlose ich euch jetzt
einfach mal ganz schnell die gewinner
und am ende des videos möchte ich euch
noch etwas erzählen was mir gestern
passiert ist also das bruchsaler set ich
war jetzt aber mit der bruchsaler set an
für die zwei kinokarten jeweils hat
gewonnen von youtube jojo msp mit herz
stunde extra dabei mit herz du hast die
zwei tickets gewonnen für bruchsal dann
die paulina paula von youtube
graf richard von youtube roja der graf
der grafik
sonja räubertochter von youtube übrigens
ganz toller film von ja heute von yahoo
28 die räder
euro die wir schon diese woche ja es ist
dass uns noch weiter hinhalten lassen
und durch gut deluxe von instagram
dann das mannheimer set hat gewonnen
like etienne doppelpunkt drei von
youtube dann dennis curling von youtube
lies king and queen von youtube
regenbogen liebe 686 von youtube
deswegen liebe sehen was ist was das ist
ein schöner name version sich bisschen
morath dann die tuba seiten von facebook
dann von youtube 68 71 69
dann die restlichen von instagram die
unterschrift fehle
ich habe probleme mit euren namen ockert
dann alle unterstrich acht princess
unterstrich polina 88 und rocker das
sind die instagram gewinnen und die
gewinner für das deutschlandweite das
war heiss begehrt weiß natürlich nicht
nur regional sondern für ganz
deutschland gilt und weil dann natürlich
auch noch die fanartikel dabei sind
biene alia von youtube hat es runter
corina gakkai von facebook
marcel schäfer von facebook den spott
von facebook will ja den kenne ich sogar
hat doch eine facebook seite mit ganz
viel tolle leckeren rezepten ich glaube
backen macht spaß wie heißt die seite
macht spaß und ich hoffe aufrichtig und
von instagram philips unterstrich also
wir machen das jetzt so etwa herzlichen
glückwunsch an alle gewinner und vielen
dank an alle die mitgemacht haben
ich freue mich darüber dass ihr gewonnen
habt und wünsche dir anfangen anderen
einfach beim nächsten mal wieder ganz
viel glück und viel erfolg
es kommt ja bald wieder ein
250.000 abonnenten und bei 150000 habe
ich euch ja versprochen da gibt es dann
eine küchenmaschine und das versprechen
halte ich natürlich oder vor dass es
bald soweit ist ich würde sagen die
gewinner die bei instagram schicken mir
einfach eine privat mache ich bei
instagram die gegner von facebook
schicken mir
einem eintrag auf der chronik ich
kontakt ihr euch dann privat und die
gehen wir noch von youtube ihr könnt mir
eine e mail an sales torten welt
gmail.com schicken mit dem betreff
gewinn und das am besten so in den
nächsten paar stunden dass ich einfach
alles am wochenende jetzt verschicken
kann und ihr alle eure preise bekommt
das war jetzt ein sehr freudiges thema
und jetzt kommen wir zu einem thema was
mich sehr bedrückt wer mich bei facebook
abonniert hat also da auf meiner seite
mich verfolgt der hat es auch gestern
schon mit gelesen und weiß um was es
jetzt geht und zwar saß ich ich als ich
erzählt diesmal allem die jetzt noch
nicht bei facebook mit dabei sind und
zwar sah sich gestern gerade daheim
haben video fertig gedreht habe mich
gerade um fragen gekümmert und
beantwortet und dann hat es bei mir an
der tür klingelt und meine freundin
stand plötzlich in der tür und hat
gesagt so jetzt ist es soweit die
flüchtlinge sind bei uns in waghäusel
angekommen und in dem moment war ich
irgendwie total schockiert ich wusste
zwar dass sie bei uns ankommen ich
wusste aber nicht wann sie kommen und
jetzt ist also jetzt sind ungefähr 80
personen also 80 flüchtlinge bei uns in
waghäusel untergekommen diese woche und
ich sehe euch einfach mal ganz kurz wie
eben die situation wir haben waghäusel
hier so ein südzucker gelände also
früher war der fabrik und da wird jetzt
nicht mehr gearbeitet das ist im
industriegebiet und da sie jetzt einfach
container aufgestellt und in einem
container haben praktisch 35 personen
platz und das müsst ihr euch so
vorstellen das ist doch ein ganz langer
flur rechts und links sind ganz viele
zimmer und pro zimmer sind drei betten
drin also ein hochbett und ein
einzelbett und das heißt pro zimmer
schlafen oder drei personen
und pro container also für 35 personen
gibt es zwei kleine kochnische und es
gibt jeweils eine frauen und männer
toilette und da sind halt jetzt 80
personen untergekommen und wohnen da
jetzt praktisch und da gibt es eine
verwaltung wo daneben menschen arbeiten
die sich daneben von morgens bis abends
darum kümmern dass da einfach alles
glatt läuft dass es da sauber bleibt
dass die menschen da angemeldet werden
und dass sie eben versorgt werden und
einfach dass alles geregelt wird und man
bemüht sich doch auch wirklich dass da
alles sauber ist weil man muss jetzt mal
überlegen das sind 35 menschen in einem
großen container sie müssen sich eine
oder beziehungsweise 2 küchenzeilen
teilen sie müssen sich zwei toiletten
und duschen teilen und es ist ja klar
für uns ist das eher unvorstellbar weil
wir leben hier zum beispiel zutritt in
der wohnung ich habe einen bart ich habe
eine küche ich habe mein schlafzimmer
samira hat ihr zimmer und für uns da ist
unvorstellbar noch mit 32 anderen
personen unser bad teilen zu müssen
beziehungsweise dass wir um auf die
toilette zu gehen irgendwie erst mal aus
unserem zimmer raus müssen also aus der
wohnung raus müssen das ist ja so eine
vorstellung
das kennt man hier in deutschland
einfach gar nicht und klar die leute
sind jetzt hier auch in sicherheit und
alles aber es fehlt einfach auch noch
vieles und ich habe dann auch gestern
einfach spontan
das eben dort besucht und waren auch am
abend total bedrückt und habe da eben
auch ganz viele kinder gesehen das sind
ich weiß nicht genau die zahl aber ich
glaube es sind 20 kinder vom
säuglingsalter bis
16 glaube ich war ja die meisten sind
einfach kinder und jugendliche und dass
die noch ältere menschen dabei da war
auch ein älteres ehepaar dabei wo der
mann zum beispiel an krebs erkrankt ist
und die leben da ist praktisch in dem
zimmer und st ja
ja so das war echt erschreckend gestern
und auch total traurig die menschen dazu
zu sehen und ich meine die sprechen alle
kein deutsch und für uns ist ja dann
auch natürlich das problem ich meine da
gibt es die initiative jetzt dafür ich
werde euch da auch den link in der
infobox packung habe ich auch gestern
auf facebook schon geteilt da gibt es
einfach die wahl seiner initiative die
sich jetzt darum kümmert und da kommen
dann jetzt auch menschen die vielleicht
die gleiche sprache sprechen und dann
sich einfach verständigen können dass
denen einfach geholfen wird und ich habe
da zum beispiel aus wissen land so von
zimmer zu zimmer haben da die leute
besucht und einfach gefragt ob es ihnen
noch etwas fehlt und die meisten sagen
uns fehlt an nix aber du siehst einfach
die haben die haben gar nichts und es
fehlt eigentlich an allem und es werden
zb noch kinderwägen benötigt es werden
noch kinder kleidung benötigt es wird
damit man die kinder überhaupt mal baden
kann werden so kinder waren benötigt
weil du kannst ja nicht sollten einfach
in die dusche stecken das geht ja gar
nicht die branche da extreme wanne dafür
und jetzt ist einfach so dass wir ein
spendenaufruf gemacht haben gestern also
ich auf meiner seite und dieser
initiative und es haben sich gestern
schon so viele menschen bei facebook
gemeldet und ich war da echt total
glücklich drüber und ich hab dann die
sachen gelesen hatte ich tränen in den
augen weil manche geschrieben obwohl ich
hab kein geld aber ich hab so viel
kleider noch von meinem kind und wird es
euch einfach gerne schicken ich habe
noch kinder decken oder mützen schals
alles mögliche und die leute haben sich
gestern echt schon oder ihr gesagt habt
euch gestern extrem hingestellt und mir
einfach geschrieben wo kann ich das
paket hinschicken die adresse wo er das
hinschicken können schreibe ich euch
alles in die infobox ich schreibe es
auch bei facebook und bei instagram und
ich finde es einfach wahnsinnig toll wie
viele leute
sich einfach jetzt engagieren und helfen
wollen und ihr wisst ja ich habe ja
dieses video gemacht ich bin dann also
land ich bin ein mensch und habe da
schon ein spendenkonto eingerichtet und
jetzt ist es einfach so weit dass wir
jetzt dieses geld was schon
zusammengekommen ist nutzen können und
können zum beispiel auch windeln kaufen
oder einfach sachen kaufen die jetzt
eben gebraucht werden und wer gerne
jetzt noch mal helfen möchte kann es
wirklich tun das spendenkonto verlinke
ich auch nochmal unten in der infobox
und auch bei facebook und es wird auf
jeden fall noch mal ein video dazu geben
ich zeige auch die räumlichkeiten es
muss einfach noch abgeklärt werden ob
man das drehen darf und ich würde mich
auf jeden fall freuen wenn ihr all oder
mit macht und uns helft und
und gestern war es dann eben noch so wir
haben dann natürlich auch gleich gefragt
was ich denn mit den kindern denn die
müssen ja in kindergärten usw im moment
hat es leider bisher wenig plätze arbeit
ich stark bemüht sich darum die kinder
in kindergärten unterzubringen damit die
einfach auch unter andere kinder kommen
und auch deutsch lernen
das problem ist einfach ihr müsst euch
mal überlegen die kinder sitzen jetzt da
in containern im gewerbegebiet und die
können ja auch gar nicht raus weil
draußen außerhalb des containers ist nur
beton und es gibt einfach nichts
es gibt das ist einfach so abgelegen von
der stadt dass die nicht mal zu fuß
irgendwie auch ein spielplatz oder so
können also das ist wirklich im
gewerbegebiet eben industriegebiet und
die leute müssen zum beispiel zum
einkaufen
ich weiß nicht genau wie viele kilometer
das sind 34 kilometer hin laufen und die
sachen dann zu fuß wieder bar zum
container transportieren da stand zum
beispiel vorgestern die schwangere die
hochschwangere die erwartet in zwei
wochen ihr kind stand da und wollt
wasser holen gehen und dir ist ja
niemals transportieren können und er hat
sich zum glück eine ehrenamtliche dazu
bereit erklärt die warte hat zufällig da
und hab dann sie hin und her gefahren
dann aber gestern in einem raum in einem
raum haben einer familie getroffen die
sind aus nigeria die sprechen natürlich
dann auch nur englisch und da kommt man
sich wenigstens verständigen und da hat
der mann zum beispiel gesagt er habe
einen dreijährigen sohn und der sphinx
und süß war der hat dann damit sein ball
bisschen gespielt und der mann hat als
sonst sagt ob wir nicht irgendein
fernseher oder so hätten und da hab ich
erst hat er was wegen des im fernseher
also da da gibt es auch sachen die noch
notwendiger sind und dann hat exakt
sally wie ich weiß nicht mal wie ich
mein kind beschäftigen soll ja es stimmt
wenn ich überlegt wen ich allein mit
dass amira daheim bin den ganzen tag in
einem raum in einem raum wie soll ich
das kind beschäftigen dem ganzen
taktisch nicht mehr spielsachen dabei
und der junge ist drei jahre alt der hat
nur mit ball und ich glaube ein
spielzeugauto und dann haben extra teil
stimmt wir müssen ihm aus auftreiben
dann hat unsere freundin die saskia
gesagt du ich habe von meinem sohn
gerade soviel spielsachen da spielt doch
gar nicht damit ich bring es ihn hin da
haben die ihm das gebracht mit meinem
schwager zusammen und mein schwarzer
sally ich habe noch nie im leben ein
kind gesehen was ich so arg über
spielsaal gefreut hat also es war echt
richtig schön natürlich dieses
gesellschaftlich die wohnung jetzt wie
so oft über in deutschland werden die
leute dann im gewerbegebiet abgeschoben
das heißt weit weg von jeglicher
zivilisation
und die vision nur menschen integrieren
ihnen den du sie ging in
gewerbegebiete abschied dh anstatt den
menschen unter uns zu lassen mit denen
zu reden und sie zu zeigen und unsere
kultur hier zu zeigen 10 fußballvereine
mitzunehmen irgendwie schieben wir diese
leute in gewerbegebiete ab und
überlassen sie ihrem schicksal
da gibt es einige wenige ehrenamtliche
was wahnsinnig cool finde die da helfen
weil beim wäsche sortieren und allem
drum und dran aber einfach diese
menschen abzuschieben und aus unserer
mitte heraus oder nachher sagen hey die
leben der parallelgesellschaft die
menschen sind die sich nicht integrieren
dass ich etwas grauenvolles mich ist
international aber sie können auch
menschen die gut integriert
wir stecken ja gar nicht mit denen also
wir überlassen sie einfach ihrem
schicksal
die müssen von amt zu amt ihre sachen
erledigen ich finde man sprechen viele
leute kein englisch ja nicht mal der
deutschen verstehen also wer die
deutsche sprache mächtig sind verstehen
einmal die amtssprache ist
wir haben wir haben uns doch damals
waren beinahe studiert haben mussten wir
ein wohngeld bescheid ausfüllen und
selbst da haben wir probleme gehabt und
diese leute
das ist ich kann einfach nicht mehr dass
sie schon mal von den augen hält und
sagt hey wie in was für einer welt leben
wir eigentlich das sind so viele
verschiedene leute aus verschiedenen
gründen sind sie hier die einen christen
grund verfolgt welche christen sind die
anders moslems die anderen sind kurden
die anderen kommen aus syrien
wir sind so viele verschiedene völker
guten mal jetzt braucht man nicht sagt
heil wir müssen den moslems helfen den
christen helfen das ist allen möglichen
gruppen hintzen kinder wirklich kinder
wenn wir dies dann kann man einfach
nicht mehr wirklich und und ich bitte
euch bitte ich habe es gab noch nie so
viele video redet unterstützt uns
unterstützt auch die initiativen bei
euch im okt wo hilfe gebraucht wird
spendet redet mit diesen leuten geht hin
rest geht darum dass man jetzt unmengen
von sachen spendet es geht einfach darum
dass man sich um die menschen einfach
kümmert also wir haben jetzt auch im rat
beschlossen ich möchte dort deutsch
kurse anbieten gerade auch für die
kinder dass die einfach eine
beschäftigung bekommen wer wurde zum
beispiel auch das schul hälfte kommt
stifter die hat die haben gestern mit
zur schaumstoff
sachen gespielt als das war kein
spielzeug in meinen augen und einfach
dass die beschäftigung haben die können
nichts anderes machen oder wir packen
mal alle kinder ein und gehen auch ein
spielplatz oder so weil die könne da ich
den ganzen tag nichts anderes machen als
einfach den tag lang in ihrem container
abzusitzen die können immer spazieren
gehen
die leute doch die sind echt berührt
also die initiativen die verwaltung ist
ein echt bemüht alles geregelt zu halten
alles sauber zu halten und das ist auch
echt toll dass sie sich alles so
engagieren und ich denke da können wir
als normalbürger einfach alle mithelfen
und zur bisschen verantwortung mittragen
mich wundert es auch nicht dass diese
leute einfach betrübt nur aggressiv
werde überlegt wo man ist es wie wir
menschen im käfig gehalten und wie die
sally grad gesagt habe wir ob die ganzen
tag mit mit irgendwelche fremden leuten
den container drin oder in norf vier
wänden
fernsehen ihr habt keine
kulturellen möglichkeiten zeitung
fußballverein zu spielen oder oder was
oder zu arbeiten arbeiten müssen die ja
auch nicht das heißt ja nicht dürfen es
nicht und das ist doch einfach furchtbar
wie sich für uns wirklich für uns
deutsche hier oder auch für die türken
die hier leben und und alt und hatte
sich für uns etwas unvorstellbares ist
das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen
also wie gesagt es werden auf jeden fall
kleider benötigt und alles was ich schon
genannt haben schulhefte tafeln dass
sich da einfach ich wohl auch andere
dass wir dadurch deutschkurse geben
können es werden auch fahrräder benötigt
damit die leute auch zum einkaufen
fahren können oder einfach zum essen
fahren können einfach dass sie da mal
weg kommen können
und ich find's einfach toll wenn ihr
einfach euch engagiert ich weiß ihr habt
alle ein tolles herz und gutes herz und
setzt bayer nicht mit sachspenden oder
mit oder finanziell helfen kann kann
einfach mal schauen ob er in seiner
region nicht irgendwie so eine
initiative unterstützen kann oder
einfach die gemeinde geht einfach zur
gemeinde und fragt einfach mal nach und
ich möchte unter dem video jetzt
eigentlich auch gar keine kommentare
haben wie sally doors so ein tolles herz
denn das bin nicht ich das ist die
gemeinde das ist die initiative
es sind einfach ganz viele andere
menschen die da ehrenamtlich helfen und
sich einfach darum kümmern und ich weiß
einfach dass auch viele von euch ein
richtig großes herz besitzen ich habe
gestern auf facebook schon gesehen wie
viele von euch jetzt einfach schon
geholfen haben und noch helfen möchten
und ich denke gemeinsam können wir da
ganz viel erreichen ganz viel helfen und
ich freue mich einfach auf eure
kommentare und auch eure hilfe und fragt
einfach mal nach ob ihr helfen könnt
alle informationen stehen jetzt bei mir
in der infobox schreibe ich aber auch
auf facebook ich poste auch auf
instagram damit wir einfach alle
erreichen können und ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei euch einen auch fürs
zuschauen jetzt bis zum ende und ja ich
bin durch einen noch einen ganz schönen
tag gestand